[Music]
the basic idea of Heaven's Gate was that
you would chemically and biologically
transform your body becoming a next
level alien
alien or the UFO
when is the end of the world find out on
this episode of LED live
[Music]
welcome to LED live we are back in the
studio talking today about when the end
of the world is with all this talk about
the end of the world you know with China
Wars and and Russia Wars and Ukraine
Wars everyone's talking right now about
the end of the world what is that what
does that mean but before we get into it
I want to thank you I think our patreons
for helping us out patreon.com
littleized Studios help us out because
we can't do this without you super super
good information that we released
pre-release on there that you want to be
a part of also you can go to
lightweird.shop and get some cool
t-shirts like me and Scotty has on look
at that
that's right mine's not printer yet yeah
that's right but you should go there and
check it out so today we're talking
about the end of the world the end of
the world what do you think about the
end of the world good subject yeah I
like this subject actually that's coming
soon I'm ready for it are you yeah yeah
it's it's Lots can happen at the end of
the world and Bible reveals a lot of
stuff but did you know that people have
predicted the end of the world
In Our Lifetime several times yeah what
kind of people I've heard I've heard a
lot of predictions yeah you've been
predicting like when the end of the
world is going to come about yeah and
they they believed that a certain date
was going to be set and the end was
going to come you know all those dates
happened come and gone nothing happened
I'm gonna go in chronological order and
so the first one that was done this is
the first one can you think of the first
one
beef just after you were born do you
remember which one that was maybe not
everybody yet I remember why why 2K okay
all right but that that that was more or
less they they figured it was going to
be a complete meltdown before that I
don't remember if there was ever an end
of the world scenario
I mean
yeah not that I can think of
so there was one we're going to talk
about how every time that this one has
happened
has predict people have predicted the
end of the world check this out and it
was that new science that new technology
that then sparked a fear that Halley's
Comet
would end life on Earth
as collision with the tail approach news
around the world began to take on a
manic tone the Tacoma times reported
that Korean officials feared that the
comet was an ill Omen Chris former Vice
Minister thought it was a sign for
telling the downfall of the present
Imperial Dynasty perhaps it was a few
months later Japan annexed Korea a
missionary in China reported that logos
for the comet indicates calamity
reports of suicides and Madness caused
by the comet were commonplace hoaxes too
such as the widely reported story of a
cult that attempted to sacrifice a
virgin in Oklahoma
an article suggested that people could
survive the comet by renting a submarine
a French scientist thought the comet
could cause an extraordinary Deluge of
rain professor in California was
concerned that Cyanogen would combine
with hydrogen to create hydrocyanic acid
reporters have bounded that if the comet
hit the planet Earth it would blow up
like a firecracker or that they come
would pull up the oceans by their roots
despite the misinformation and fear for
the most part people were simply
interested in viewing something historic
scientists assured readers that probably
they should be totally unaware passing
through the tail
Comet parties became All the Rage from
Hawaii to Paris as the fateful day
approach some reached hysterics people
taped up doors to keep the possible gas
out and was reported that churches were
filled with fearful congregations
less dramatically some thought the tale
might slightly change the color of the
sky for a time or interfere with
compasses or Telegraph messages
the tale was scheduled to hit the planet
during the night of May 19th many
millions stayed up across the world to
see what would happen to be present at
what could be the end of days postcards
dated with May 20th declared in various
languages that it would be fiend
hotels across the world had roof parties
but Marion and some other friend
scientists rented out the Eiffel Tower
to observe the comet
the New York Herald reported that miners
in Pennsylvania refused to work in the
days leading up to the event and some
Farmers took down lightning rods so they
wouldn't attract anything from the comet
on May 18th a group of people barricaded
themselves in a cave and a poem and
another paper implored the comet that it
brushed the Earth gently with its tail
England saw violent thunderstorms and
for Marion reported that some observers
had certain Ola Factory experiences
many watched and saw
absolutely nothing
and that's what happened so this was
what happened previously when Haley's
comment came around and it happened
again in 1986. so I do remember Haley's
comment yeah but but I I guess I was
really young
um I mean I would have been around like
uh eight in the in that age range and so
I don't remember them talking about the
end of the world I remember them you
know discussing maybe it was going to
hit the Earth or something like that or
could potentially but I wouldn't think
it would blow up the whole world some of
that comment in comparison to the world
I mean the pictures the illustrations
they look small I don't know why there's
so much fear about the destroying the
world yeah these are part of the world
they wanted they thought that the tail
was going to cause gas that goes into
the world and and people were like
sealing up their doors to make sure I
thought that was weird that's
interesting but I mean that's how that's
how this stuff goes sometimes someone
says something and it blows out of
proportion you never know there was
another instance that happened before
Y2K can you think of it it's in 1996
that someone predicted the end of the
world
future
it might have been this is his name like
camping or something no no no we're
getting there though we're getting there
I don't know how far the champion
talking about it but that that might
have been in the mid to late 2000s like
2010-ish yeah I can't think of one check
this out check this out
October 1996. Rancho Santa Fe California
Marshall Applewhite and his followers
have created a website which outlines
their beliefs and explains how one may
enter Heaven's Gate the basic idea of
Heaven's Gate was that you would
chemically and biologically transform
your body becoming a Next Level alien
and then you would
UFO which would sail off into heaven
says Heaven's Gate away team
March 19 1997. in the backyard of their
home Heaven's Gate members videotape one
another issuing farewell messages to the
world
so can you believe these people were so
deceived by this that they believed that
Haley's comment if that's the right no
Heaven hail Bob that's what it was in
1997 I think I said 1996 at the
beginning they believed that this thing
was coming and it was going to take them
away and they would have to commit
suicide and so this whole suicidal thing
happened they died yeah there was a
number of them 30 or 80 or I can't
remember what the number was before yeah
I do remember this yeah and so I didn't
think it was a end of the world though
did they think it was going to destroy
the world they thought they both they
thought that the the world was was was
over and this thing was going to take
them away but and if you didn't get on
it then you're left behind sort of sort
of thing I guess you know the crazy
thing is is like death like asleep right
these people are literally I mean to
them the next moment they think of
they're gonna wake up they're gonna
think of that but then you know when
they come to the realization that a lot
of time has passed that's right
kinesiastes 9-5 says that the dead know
nothing right so is that Ecclesiastes
9-5 I'm gonna look that up again yeah
but we're all going to raise from the
dust of the earth to a judgment so
they're going to be like we're here
[Music]
and and that's so that's what happened
back then and then there was my two kids
why 2K emergency calls went through the
power stayed on and we didn't go back
into the Dark Ages but at this time on
New Year's Eve of 1999 no one knew for
sure what was going to happen with the
Y2K bug a line of computer code that
could not recognize dates Beyond 1999
sent many people into a panic 20 years
ago thousands of Americans will be
spending the night at the last place
they might have expected almost everyone
is preparing for the worst potential Y2K
computer crashes top the list in Jersey
City 400 Bankers will be ready to take
calls from investors they know they got
to be working and they know that's the
priority and in other cities across the
country tens of thousands of police
officers on high alert survivalists
stockpiled food and everyone waited to
see what would shut down when the Clock
Struck midnight in the New Millennium
many flights have been cancel here
tonight that's because of two reasons
first of all people just didn't buy the
ticket
20 years ago people relied on landline
phones the telephone companies spent
years and 275 million to prevent the
glitch from taking out telephone service
the city of Sioux Falls even hired a Y2K
planner and 12 people worked for more
than a year to prepare the city so we're
only halfway through looking at all
these different things that have
happened in our lifetime most of us 22
years ago yeah yeah and that isn't that
interesting so all this time people have
have predicted these things and and
every single time people are sure sure
are sure and it hasn't happened it
hasn't Virginia were you born in 2000
yeah did you hear this at all no you
don't remember you don't know anything
about this nope so you know when you
lived in the 90s for a thousand years or
not a thousand years in the 1900s or
yeah for a thousand years you just put
like 99 like this is the year 99 because
you already know you're in the 19
thousands or whatever so computers and
everything were programmed to just put
the last two digits so now they're like
well what happens when it rolls over now
it's going to be 1900 the computer is
going to like flip out and not know what
to do so they thought like everything
was going to crash yeah literally people
didn't get on planes like they said
because they thought the planes were
just oh zero zero
as if that would cause a plane to crash
but I mean this was a real thing they
they actually had um
committed government agencies in order
to have a specific departments to make
sure that everything was going to run
through and the world wouldn't end
because of a computer crash yeah right
and so it seems funny now that's kind of
a sad reality that we've so intertwined
ourselves with the technology that so
dependent upon it yeah that we think
that that's what would end life you know
like the technology is not going to work
anymore
with the Wi-Fi and we had so they had
all these warnings and they spent the
last few minutes to get this ready they
got you know I remember seeing Y2K
compliant stickers on things I do
remember that interesting but um Jesus
gave us warnings in the Bible and what
were some of those warnings he gave us
there'll be Wars rumors of wars natural
disasters
yes elements will
Rock to and fro yeah the the Earth will
wax
um old I think it says
yeah that's that as the verbiage
so check this out Matthew 24 44 be ready
for the son of man is coming at an hour
you do not expect
Luke 21 34 take heed to yourselves lest
you your hearts be weighed down with
carousing drunkenness and cares of this
life that that day come when you least
expect it come on when that day comes
unexpectedly
and Matthew 24-37
as in the days of nowhere were so also
were the coming of the son of man be
what does that mean
uh you know the days of Noah was
described as
every person their heart the
imaginations of their heart was only
evil continually
and it sounds like man that's kind of
extreme like are we there yet but it's
man we're getting close I think people
are just
it might not be what people expect to be
evil but I think so much wickedness is
accepted now that they're thinking evil
thoughts and they don't even realize
it's evil
I I think it doesn't help when a lot of
our media is flipping the script on that
and people are really confused on even
what evil is is it good is it evil is it
like you know it's all jumbled around at
this point yeah no I remember um do you
remember Daniel Dodson I think that's
what his name was he was in the you'll
remember this by the the song that came
out about him so um there was a guy in
the projects and he uh had a song made
about him that was on the news about
someone climbing in the window snatching
his ear I don't remember this Hide Your
Kids
find your husband so I think that's
interesting because I I um I when that
came out I grabbed that clip and I put
it in the Sodom and Gomorrah commentary
not commentary but actual Bible verses
that as they were speaking it
dramatically uh in my audio Bible and it
flowed so well it was really funny but
at the same time it was kind of sobering
because it it showed that
what was happening back then
is what's happening now that wasn't
necessarily in the days of Noah but
that's it's interesting that we are
coming full circle as as Things become
well you said sodomorrah there is
another verse that says as in the days
of lot so there is there is Noah and lot
these are descriptions of how the world
is going to be when he comes back
absolutely
there is another one that's already been
mentioned that's happened in our
lifetime well people thought that the
world was going to end 2012 2012 2012
that's right so there's actually a
couple of them that's happened in 2012.
check this out
Billboards proclaiming imminent doomsday
are popping up all over the U.S Judgment
Day is at hand according to a Christian
radio preacher in California if
90-year-old Harold camping's bible-based
calculations are correct you shouldn't
be making any plans past Saturday May
21st May 21 there's going to be a
terrific earthquake way way greater than
anything that the Earth has ever
experienced and that'll be the beginning
of judgment day we have no plan B it is
going to happen you know the Bible is a
very factual book it has given us an
example after example of when God has
predicted something prophesied something
was going to happen however
however impossible it might look it
always has happened
except when it hasn't like the last time
camping predicted Armageddon in 1994 and
nothing happened so I think that's
interesting because this this guy
predicted the end of the world he didn't
have a lot to back up what he was saying
but he was so factual about it and he
was so old and people took his word for
it because he was a pastor
and they accepted it then it made the
news why is how does he make Nationwide
news just by being a pastor in
California or whatever
and I mean what did that do to people's
Faith like right not not just people who
are Christians or maybe young people who
are raised in the church and like man
this stuff's bogus but like onlookers we
are being watched the world is watching
us to see if we're legit like if okay if
you're a Christian this is the truth I'm
watching you I'm going to see if your
life's different or whatever and then
you're saying stuff like this that
doesn't credit the Bible do you remember
if like they sold everything and like
was there like a huge kind of financial
component to that because it seems like
if you really thought it was the end of
the world I mean really thought it was
the end of the world wouldn't you just
drain your bank account and be like last
ditch effort everybody should know about
this you know yeah like put it into
Billboards and all that yeah and I think
I remember them them talking about a
little bit about some of those financial
ramifications of of you know people that
actually believed in this and then you
know it's like gave up a lot of their
belongings and things and then all of a
sudden it doesn't happen and destroys
people's faith
I think it's really interesting how
like he said that the Bible is very
factual and all of this and I agree that
it's very factual but then the Bible
also said that you're not going to know
the time right when the world will end
but he's giving a specific time so I
just think it's interesting he acted
like he got it right out of the Bible
like yeah it's here and the Bible says
it and prophecy is true it's like I'm
sure people brought that up to him yeah
I mean that's a good point I'm sure
people you know hey Mr Campion like this
this is what this verse says here the
day and hour you will not know yeah that
was just for the people that he was
speaking to at that moment yeah that's
the excuse I've heard that before I've
heard people say when Jesus said that he
was talking to a specific people no one
here knows but in the future they'll
know
you know a lot of people think that a
lot of people have misconceptions about
the return of Jesus which is the true
end of the world they believe that only
a few people are going to see this
return of Christ and they believe that
it's uh it's only it's only for a select
few well everybody could enjoy it if
they accept right but watch watch this
Revelation 170 pulled he is coming with
clouds and every eye will see him
so is it going to be just a secret thing
everybody's gonna see it it's going to
be absolutely going to be a a huge it
even talks about people hiding in the
caves and let the Rocks crush me because
they're trying to hide from the Wrath of
the Lamb
so yeah it wouldn't make sense that only
a couple people are seeing them yeah
yeah absolutely
what's the other 2012 event that
happened December 21st 2012 the end of
the Mayan calendar drawn up by an
ancient civilization thousands of years
ago in France True Believers flocked to
a peak in the Pyrenees Mountains
believing it was the only place in the
world that was safe
thousands of tourists flock to Mexico
hoping to celebrate a new era in an
ancient Mayan city
at the Thirsty Dog Brewing Company in
Akron Ohio there is a special beer for
the occasion the first crucial hurdle
for mankind Asia where midnight came and
went and Humanity carried on but the
Mayans were from the Western Hemisphere
maybe they were on New York time all
right here we are in Times Square the
place where Humanity rings in New Year's
to find out if it's our final year our
last few moments on Earth ABC News has
trusted me with this assignment the
potential scoop of all Scoops not that
anyone's going to be around to hand out
any promotions but the hour draws near
the moment of truth is here there's the
clock
three two one okay there you have it
folks we are still here John Muller
reporting exclusively for ABC News the
end of the world has not happened we are
still here
I put a clock in New York just for the
Mayan calendar thing
I I don't know you have to admire the
human Ingenuity to profit off of uh
something like this we have a special
beer yeah all right oh my goodness but
see this is this is kind of the result
of that if you make a prediction like
that then all of a sudden it's like
people are not going to listen to a
message where I think the the message
that that the time is short is designed
to ready our hearts and always be ready
you know I think just human nature God
knew he knows the heart he knows that
we're all a bunch of procrastinators and
if he told us the time we would say okay
well I got this much time to do what I
want and then I'm gonna go be like do
you want me to be just for the last
second right exactly what I was going to
say too I mean even my when I
finally reached a point where I believe
the Bible is true I believe God's
answered my prayers I still was like
okay I know you're real let me have some
fun when I'm on my death bed I'm going
to invite you in I'm going to heaven
like that's what a terrible motive you
know like yeah and you know what I see a
lot of times in churches is that last
deathbed uh generation I hate to say it
that way but I mean you have you have
everybody that lives their life up to a
point and then they get inside the
church so they can learn as much as they
can and they sleep through it in their
Pew and I and just it just saddens me
because there's so much you can learn
from this stuff and there's so much so
many that think this that don't even
understand the specifics that God wants
them to understand I Think Jesus spoke
of the urgency
um you know in his day he was saying you
know time is short the Kingdom of Heaven
is at hand right and he's like talking
about this that we can easily look this
side of the time clock and be like well
there's kind of a lot of time that
transpired in there but in actual
reality if you think about the the sort
of urgency of our lifespan is no
different than the same lifespan as
someone else has had so we are all
really given this allotted short time
yeah 80 year old yeah but people back
then lived to be hundreds of years old
and stuff well Auntie deluvians yes but
um you know around Christ's day they
were still living close to 100 years old
and probably a lot less actually
um so uh we we I think are given that
same sense of of time and I think that
urgent message is for relevant to us
today yeah and we don't know when we're
gonna die so we could be living Our
Lives you know doing what we want
instead of doing what Christ wants and
all of a sudden boom it's over I mean
accidents happen Solomon says time and
chance happens to us all I mean so not
only is is uh is God involved in every
part of our life but also things happen
I mean we can cause accidents we could
die it's not God's will yeah we're
driving 70 miles an hour with people all
around you like
it's amazing that we'd make it through
that every day
we fly all the time like we're like a
thousand I don't know how thousands of
feet up in the air and you're just like
yeah we put ourselves in a lot of risky
positions so the Bible says that these
things are are um are going to happen
but um a lot of people believe that the
end of the world is secret like we
talked about let's see what the Bible
says about that real quick first
Thessalonians 4 16 the Lord himself will
descend from heaven in a shout
the voice of the Archangel and with the
trumpet of God and the dead in Christ
will rise first does that sound like a
quiet a quiet end of the world to you no
I think the culmination of I mean not
only like what humans have looked
forward since the beginning of time but
think about all of Heaven is is engaged
in this war that's the culmination final
moment of their ending of all this like
I'm sure it's in in a heaven sense it's
going to be a grand Fanfare okay we're
done let's go let's go by and pick them
up you know what I mean what a what a
sad state if you're like oh yeah like
only a couple people are gonna know and
they're out in the desert and you know
it's like a bunch of hippies with
funnels on their head you know it says
that there's going to be this shout
there's going to be a trumpet there's
going to be the dead in Christ arising
there's people going to be rising from
the dead yeah yeah that's not gonna how
is that a secret yeah yeah wow I mean
talk about an earthquake can you imagine
everyone coming out of the graves and
everything yeah all right so I think
it's neat that the Bible uses the word
trumpet too is the trumpet is generally
known as a very loud instrument but if
you really kind of let the Bible
interpret itself the answers are
actually in the Bible we don't have to
like make things up and you know what I
mean and some people like say oh you
know it's it's very confusing actually
that sounds pretty plain to me you know
it's going to be loud there's gonna be a
trumpet yeah it's the doctrines that
people have made that make it confusing
like well I've heard this but it doesn't
really seem like it lines up
yeah absolutely there's one more into
the world scenario but actually this
isn't over yet so don't don't close out
this is this is an interesting one I had
not seen this one I I must have missed
it during the time that I was here and
there but yeah
don't even say that word I just got our
video flagged no
um the uh but it's it's check this out
this is this is this is an interesting
one
[Music]
I believe
that the heavens are God's billboard
that he has been sending signals to
planet Earth and we just haven't been
picking them up
I'm going to walk you through 500 years
and show you how God is literally
screaming at the world I'm coming soon
[Applause]
the coming Four Blood Moons points to a
world-shaking event
that will happen between April 2014 and
October
2015. Jesus said in Mark 13 24 26 but in
those days
the sun shall be darkened and the moon
shall not give its light then they shall
see the son of man coming in the Clouds
Of Heaven with power and great Glory
that verse describes a time in the
future when the sun and the moon will
eclipse at the same time and God sends
planet Earth a signal that something big
is about to happen he's controlling the
Sun and the Moon right now to send our
generation a signal but the question is
are we getting it
yeah John Hagee I've seen that guy he um
I remember one time he was talking about
the pre-tribulation Rapture or he was
talking about end times events and stuff
and then he was just like but we're not
going to be here for that praise the
Lord and everybody stands like
like they were like the church erupted
when he said but we're not going to be
here for that
and I was like whoa dude like where does
he get that from that we're not going to
be here through the tribulation and
until Jesus comes back every every
scenario in the Bible every story that
is our example to look through in the
Old Testament shows God's people going
through a tough time with God with them
before they enter the promised land
before they receive the the promise
before they received the prize and there
is no situation where God's like yep you
don't have to go through a hard time
don't worry about it we'll take you out
of there yeah I mean the Israelites were
in Egypt while the plagues were coming
down that's a perfect parallel to the
plagues in Revelation
why would we think we're not going to be
there
um Noah you know the flood was coming
and the wicked were destroyed and no it
was still there right he was just
protected through that destruction
there was another example I was thinking
but it talks about how Satan is going
after those who keep the Commandments of
God the the Beast has power to overcome
the Saints I mean like so that's when I
first started questioning this stuff I
was studying with a guy who was saying
you know we believe the pre-trib Rapture
I said well where's it at he said well
we're changing a moment of Twinkle and I
and I'm like okay I see that I don't see
it on some timeline before their heads
are cut off like right here I just I see
they had power to overcome the Saints
those who don't take the mark of the
beast get their heads cut off and all
this stuff I'm like he said well that's
the tribulation Saints people who are
left behind and they make a decision
they kind of get like a second chance
I'm like
it just doesn't add up with a lot of
things because I say that the holy
spirit is going to be removed and if the
holy spirit is not on Earth then how are
you going to how are you going to come
to Christ yeah this holy spirit that
leads you to Christ so there's a lot of
air and there's no Second Chances right
there's no Second Chances ever anywhere
in in the Bible yeah when judgment comes
it comes it's over yeah that's Satan's
solution is to say hey there's a second
chance though you have to worry about it
live your life the way you want and then
you can decide afterwards if you see the
signs and that's that's another thing
Jesus said there will be no sign give us
a sign an adulterous generation wants to
see a sign and there'll be no sign and
I've heard people even say yeah the
tribulation is a sign for the Jews Jesus
very specifically said there will be no
sign
and the the
um Moon turning blood red that's
happened right
historically yeah I'm sure yeah that
seems like a very common cycle or
something yeah it's a cycle and I mean
these things will happen but I think
they'll happen more dramatically as we
get down because there's there's a
number of things that happen in the
Bible and he can't just pick out one or
two little weird events and say well
look Jesus is coming because we know
because there's been Blood Moons you're
not reading the whole Bible so it's it's
definitely interesting there's a lot of
different things that kind of point to
the coming of Jesus to the end of the
world who will be with Jesus when he
comes I mean this is this is the
question that I think is is very
important because it's going to reveal
what's going to happen at the end
there's going to be a lot of stuff
happening it's going to be loud it's
going to be boisterous check this out
this is what I found Matthew 25 31 when
the son of man comes in his glory and
all the Holy Angels with him then he
will sit on the throne of his glory so
who's with him his angels yeah not just
some
everything yeah I think that they're all
going to want to see the end culmination
of of this war that's played out you
know yeah yeah and I think that's it is
that the moment that God says it is done
it's finished like isn't that verbally
spoken at that point as well and I think
I forget where it is it's in Daniel
Revelation where it says that the heaven
was quiet does it say for for a half
hour I forget it gives some some
prophetic time period where there's
nothing happening in heaven because
everyone has come to Earth to get get
the people wow and so it's really
interesting to see that there's going to
be it's going to be a big deal this is
the finale of the whole thing it's not
going to be a quiet thing
so what are some other events that that
we see happen during his return I found
some other verses pestilences famines
the sea
um turns to to death basically and
there's videos circulating saying that
the Euphrates river is drying up it's
getting lower and lower
but the sea the sea
um dies right and then is it the the you
know when the elements shake with
fervent heat and and our mountains are
cast into the sea yeah I think that's
like when right when he comes yeah are
you talking about signs leading up too
yeah even even the islands disappear
right yeah that's that's huge and so
there's there's so many things that
happen at Christ's return that it's hard
for it to become a silent thing check
this out Revelation 16 18-20 there was a
great earthquake such a mighty and green
earthquake had not that had not been
seen since there were men on Earth
then every island fled away and the
mountains were not found
Jeremiah 4 26 I beheld and indeed the
fruitful land was a Wilderness and its
cities were broken down at the presence
of the Lord broken down that's what
happens when Christ came
Isaiah 24 1-3 the Lord makes the Earth
empty and makes it waste the land shall
be entirely emptied
emptied isn't that something
because the wicked are going to be
consumed at the brightness of his coming
and the righteous are going to be caught
up to meet the Lord in the air so
there's nobody here
that's not a popular teaching though
you know a lot of people think that
there's that when he comes uh the Wicket
will be destroyed but he's going to set
up his kingdom right here on Earth for a
thousand years
there's one more interesting
characteristic you know what that is is
that just before he comes this whole
world will be
connected in a form of worship
Revelation 13 9-10 says if any man
worship the beast in His image and
receive the mark on his forehead or his
hand the same shall drink of the wine of
the wrath of God which is poured out
without mixture into a cup of his
indignation we focus so much on this
this Mark of the Beast right but we
forget what's going on at the beginning
the worship the worship yeah the worship
is what's happening and so the focus at
the very end because what is Saint Juan
according to Isaiah it says he wants to
be worshiped he wants to be as God and
so the focus is at the end worship me
because he's showing who's on his side
and who's on who's on God's side that's
his selfish desire is to be as God to be
worshiped as God and that's the ultimate
thing that's going to happen that's
going to decide if is it the true people
of God that's going to go in heaven or
is it going to be
the people are going to have to stay on
Earth be destroyed be judged I think
that's why there's a danger if the mark
of the beast is some sort of physical
tattoo element or whatever like that and
then it's like oh well as long as I
don't get that tattoo or I don't get
that chip I'm cool I can live my life
however I want and you know I I think
that really changes the context of this
this whole scenario as well
yeah because I often tell people that I
don't believe that the mark of the beast
is a physical thing and they say oh are
you saying that the chip is okay now
I'll never get a chip implant but what
I'm saying is you can avoid a microchip
at all costs and still get the mark of
the beast right that's the danger don't
I think there's going to be millions of
Christians who avoid this and think that
they've overcome the mark but right
they're going to fall for this one world
ecumenical
peace safety it looks like worldwide
Revival right people are going to think
wow like we're all coming back to God
this is Revival but really it's a false
system of worship that looks very close
to the genuine and what really woke me
up when I was trying to figure out this
whole understanding of the Bible things
is when I read in the Bible that Jesus
says he was asked Will Will just the few
get to heaven and he says be sure you
enter through the narrow gate
wide is the way to destruction
only a few people are going to so if you
see an ecumenical movement of people
going into a worship scenario no this is
not the way this is not the way that
we're supposed to go it actually says
there's going to be a falling away first
so not a big Revival first yeah I don't
know am I wrong is there is there going
to be like a great Revival of true
worship before he comes or is it going
to be like the days of Noah the days of
a lot a lot of wickedness if you
consider what happened in Noah's day
eight people got on that boat you know
how many people were actually I mean I
you got to think Noah's family's still
around right he's not the only one in
his family he's got uncles and aunts and
cousins and brothers and sisters
potentially and and they didn't get on
you know it's a it's an interesting
thought but that really tells you if
that's like an image you know it's it's
it's going to be
not the majority you know I don't know
about a small tiny you know it's not
gonna be 2 000 people so to say or
whatever but it's just it's not gonna be
the majority so I thought this was very
relevant and I thought that we should
talk about this because of all the news
media and everything that's going on
nowadays and I thought you know what who
knows maybe someone will see this and
understand what the Bible truly says
about the end of the world I think I
think the important thing to probably
put a button on this thing is is
regardless of as if it is really in the
next year or so or it's even down the
road we need to be living life like it
like it is is today they're living like
we're citizens of him exactly live as If
Today Was Your Last because you're not
guaranteed you walk out of your
workplace and you might get an accident
on the freeway the next thing you know
Jesus is coming to you right so people
every every minute find out they have
cancer and they live healthy lives and
stuff right so you know you don't know
when your end is so it's it's good to
don't be waiting for some thing to
happen before making your decision you
don't only live once hopefully you Live
Twice right so it's not YOLO right now
and and oftentimes we portray that as
hey do what you want go out and do your
thing and have fun with your life hey
you should have fun but let's have fun
in accordance to what is the best thing
for you right and so I don't think that
if we live according to what God wants
from us I don't think we're ever going
to regret that I don't think we're ever
going to be like at the end of our life
and like man I could have slept with so
many more people I could have got drunk
every night I just don't think that
we're gonna regret those decisions where
people think they're going to miss out
on something right because oh I could
have watched so many horror movies like
oh I just don't think I think God wants
us to have life more abundantly right
not staring at
terrible things all day absolutely
absolutely
thanks for watching if you were blessed
by this hit that little like button give
us a comment below maybe uh go to our
patreon.com littleline Studios and check
us out because we could always use your
support and uh we will see you next week
[Music]
foreign
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you